[Applause]
thank you for your patience
it's good to see such a great turnout
today
I hope we have a wonderful evening
on behalf of the Department of religion
studies and the department of philosophy
here at the University of Johannesburg
I welcome you to today's discussion
exploring religious belief a Muslim
atheist conversation
you will have noted that we are
envisioning today's event as a
conversation
a discussion
not a debate per se
we find ourselves in an academic setting
and the purpose of this singular space
the academy is to Foster good faith
conversations often difficult ones
about life's deepest and most important
questions
this is where we can engage in free and
open dialogue in the spirit of seeking
and I don't know how to keep the light
thank you
[Music]
in the spirit of seeking truth there was
a spirit there
whatever I don't know how to get the
light on
not imposing our views on others and
certainly not centering the views of
those with whom we disagree
we also find ourselves in Africa a
continent with the rich philosophies
around the importance of fostering
communal dialogue around matters of
great importance
and a matter of religious belief is of
great importance is it not
indeed we can consider religion to be
that couldn't essentially human activity
of engaging with matters of ultimate
importance
but it will not have escaped the
attention of anyone in this room
that the approaches
and answers to these questions
widely differ
and where we have such wide divergences
conflict can result and has resulted
time and time again throughout human
history
today we take one small step toward
perhaps breaking the cycle
but let us not be naive it won't be easy
religious questions arise from the very
core of what it means to be human you
may vehemently disagree
with one or more or all of the speakers
today even the chair
but I hope you can find the courage to
accept that free and open conversations
about truth must be fostered if Humanity
has any chance
of moving toward a new more tolerant
and tolerable future
with that said allow me to briefly
introduce you to our four esteemed
panelists
Hamza Andreas Judas
is the founder and CEO of sapiens
of the sapiens Institute he's the author
of the best-selling book The Divine
reality God Islam and a mirage of
atheism
which has been translated into over 10
languages
he has a masters of research degree
anemic and a postgraduate certificate in
Philosophy from the University of London
he is currently pursuing his PhD on the
Quran and it's a verses pertaining to
Nature he has studied Islamic thought
and theology under qualified Scholars
Hamza has spoken in many universities
all around the world
he has debated prominent academics and
thinkers on Islam and Atheism
his interlocutors have included
Professor Lawrence Krauss Professor
Peter Simmons Simons Dan Barker and
Professor Simon Blackburn
we are happy to have you here welcome
Muhammad is an author comparative
religionist and philosopher of religion
he is co-founder of the sapiens
Institute and is a researcher and
instructor for the organization he has a
ba in politics
and a master's degree in history he has
also acquired a second Masters in
Islamic Studies from the school of
Oriental and African studies he has also
completed the third master's degree in
applied theology from the University of
Oxford where he focused on the
philosophy of religion in applied
settings
he is now doing his PhD in the
philosophy of religion on the
contingency argument for God's existence
in addition he has undergone formal
training in Islamic Studies with a focus
on the Quran
prophetic traditions and legal reasoning
he he has completed Islamic Seminary
courses and has been given formal
permission to relay Islamic knowledge on
selected Islamic fields
he is one of the very few Muslim public
figures who deal comparatively with
political philosophical and Theological
issues and as such has amassed a
following of many subscribers on YouTube
in English and Arabic we are happy to
have you here welcome
is a practicing Advocate and member of
the Johannesburg bar and is
self-described philosophy enthusiast
Aaron graduated from the University of
the vitpartist run in 2007 with a ba [__]
laude
and in 2009 with an LLB [__] laude Aaron
has also graduated graduated with an MA
in applied ethics [__] laude in 2017 and
has an an M.A in philosophy cunlada in
2019. he has also been awarded his lmm
llm international law [__] laude in 2021
at the University of the vitval system
he has appeared in a number of cases
that have been reported in the South
African law reports we are happy to have
you here welcome
last but not least
we welcome Mark Oppenheimer he's a
practicing Advocate and a member of the
Johannesburg bar he has appeared in the
Supreme Court of Appeal and the
Constitutional Court in a series of
cases that seek to determine the
boundary between freedom of expression
and genuine hate speech he has altered
submissions to Parliament on the hate
speech Bill and to the U.N committee for
the elimination of racial racial
discrimination on escalating racial
tensions he is co-author of the
conversations about philosophy book
series and hosts the popular philosophy
series a brain in a vet
we are happy to have you here welcome
here quickly is the format of today's
event we will start of course with me
giving you this introduction uh once I'm
done each of the panelists will present
for 15 minutes each
we will then move to an internal
discussion amongst the panelists and
that should go for around 20 or 30
minutes
um then we will have a more open
discussion
um uh that session will be around 25
minutes that will include our esteem
panelist who I'll introduce in a moment
um they will respond and uh get the
conversation uh rolling in a different
or continue the direction that was uh
started with the internal discussion and
then they will let you the audience uh
ask questions and comments uh for around
15 minutes and may I please ask you to
keep it uh brief and concise and of
course civil
um
and we will end uh with a quick fire
around each of the panelists can
conclude in one minute just give us your
concluding thoughts
um I will send you off but before that
we have some gifts for the panelists
um uh once those gifts are given off I
will thank all of you and we will all go
home hungry
that is my hope hungry for more
conversations about these methods of
vital importance so with that said let
me introduce you to the panelists and
then we'll get the ball formerly uh
rolling to my left I have the head of
department and Senior lecturer in
philosophy Dr Chad when Harris
kill them
and then we have Dr Shia Shahid Nati
senior lecturer at the department of
religion studies welcome
we are going to go straight into the
panel discussion now which should last
us around 40 minutes
um and we are going to begin uh by
agreement of the pens uh that um
we will start with the airline faster so
Aaron fans of your 15 minutes begin now
we're looking forward to hearing what
you have to say about these masses of
all important importance thank you all
right stop by I would just like to start
by thanking organizers of this event uh
naming the philosophy of religion and
philosophy the religious studies
department for the University of
Johannesburg as well as the second
it's a great privilege to share the
stage with such esteemed learned
interlocutors conversations like this
are vitally important not only because
the topics that arise on themselves
intellectually stimulated because they
last all an opportunity to gain some
insight into the World Views and beliefs
of people vastly different from
ourselves
those attempt to deepen one's
understandings at the heart of
philosophical vessels
the philosopher gulaklima captures the
nature of what we're doing here today
and he sums it up in a foot
unless one is able to learn to think and
live with the concepts of another person
and thought objects constituted by them
one will always fail to have a real
cross on the meaning of the other person
this however need not mean that people
can understand only those persons all
whose beliefs they share what is
required for proper understanding is
rather the ability to let the other
person's belief beliefs constitute one's
own Universe support objects trying to
achieve a fusion of the horizons this
can be done however only in a long
dialectical process which may take
adjusting the beliefs of either party we
should not seek clear winning of a
debate for that is the concern of
surfaces
but to win over the other to one's
belief and or and or to be won over to
the other's belief for the sake of what
is true and good
but this of course requires openness
patience and respect from both parties
indeed this requires that attitude which
defines our profession the love of
wisdom
so with that in mind I'd like to address
two aspects in my opening address
the first relates to my understanding of
tonight's discussion topic and the
concept of rationality
the second relates to my reasons for
thinking that atheism is a more rational
philosophical position than Islamic
theism
the topic for discussion this evening is
atheism or Islam which is more rational
however what are we to what are we to
understand by the term rational
they are broadly speaking two concepts
of rationality that need to be
disambiguated the first is a lethik or
if epistemic rationality which is
concerned with truth tracking and that
set of reasons or justifications which
properly bear on the truth or policy of
someone's belief the second is pragmatic
rationality which is concerned with the
utility of a given set of beliefs in
achieving a person's stated goals
it is my understanding that the
principal concern this evening is in
determining whether atheism or Islam is
more rational in the Olympic or
epistemic sense rather than the
pragmatic sense
accordingly I understand this evening's
topic is about whether there is greater
epistemic reason to believe that atheism
or Islamic theism is true so why do I
believe that atheism is true before I
can do that I need to get some
definitions on the table so that we're
all clear about what we're talking about
by God I understand to be a single
necessary Transcendent Supernatural
immaterial non-physical person that
exists are say that is to say
independently and is essentially
omniperfect he's omnipotent omniscient
omnibeneant and thus worthy of worship
and who is the creator designer and
sustainer of the natural world
atheism is the thesis that the
proposition God exists is false theism
is the thesis that the proposition God
exists is true
naturalism is the thesis that the
proposition only the natural world
exists is true
naturalists are committed to the idea
that one there are none but natural
causal entities with none but natural
causal powers
and two our best most well-established
science is the best Touchstone for what
those natural causal entities and items
are
naturalism logically entails that
natural reality exhausts Global causal
reality and it logically entails atheism
how their atheism does not logically
entail naturalism
supernaturalism is the thesis that the
proposition only the natural world
exists is false
supernaturalism posits a bifurcated
ontological view of reality
theism entitles supernaturalism however
supernaturalism does not entail feism
supernaturalism is committed to all the
causal entities that the naturalist is
committed to plus the existence of
non-natural causal items with
non-natural causal powers
supernaturalism thus entails their
Global causal reality is not exhausted
by natural reality
by Islamic theism I understand this to
be the idea to claim that God as I've
defined him also has the property of
having progressively revealed through
the Archangel Gabriel the contents of
the Quran to Muhammad and which contents
on the final and definitive Revelation
for mankind Islamic theism logically
entails theism theism does not logically
entail Islamic it is
I am an atheist and a nationalist I
reject theism and A40 or II I reject
Islamic ideas for two principal reasons
first the arguments for the existence of
God are philosophy and persuasive we can
call this the negative reason
second they are in my view persuasive
Arguments for atheism and for
nationalism this is the affirmative
reason
the negative reason flows from the fact
that atheism is Justified in virtue of
the failure to infer God's existence and
circumstances where one would rationally
expect his existence to be inferible
absence of evidence can indeed be
evidence of absence justifying the
conclusion that something does not exist
this will be the case provided providing
at least two conditions of jointly met
first if the thing X exists then there
would be evidence of x's existence and
two we have conducted an exhaustive
search for the evidence in the areas
where such evidence or reasonably to be
found
when applied to God conditioned one is
generally accepted by all parties to the
discussion
after all if God does exist then we all
atheists emphasists alike rationally
expect there to be evidence of his
existence given the sort of being God is
supposed to be
if we do not rationally expect evidence
of his existence were he to actually
exist then it is quite difficult if not
impossible to see how one could
rationally argue for his existence in
the first place in fact the project of
national theology assumes that there
would be evidence of God's existence and
if he were to exist that we can in fact
Marshal that evidence
condition two when applied to God
amounts to dealing with the best
arguments from natural theology these
are the theistic arguments that often
invoke the inputs and insights of
contemporary science that are supposed
to take up the mantle and provide the
positive evidence from which to infer
God's existence examples include the
cosmological argument the contingency
argument the teleological argument the
moral argument Etc
we can profit the following deductive
argument which takes the above
considerations into account premise one
if God exists then there is compelling
evidence from which to infer either
deductively or non-deductively his
existence in other words the arguments
from natural theology are sound
premise 2 there is no compelling
evidence from which to install either
deductively or non-deductively God's
existence I.E the arguments of natural
theology are not sound therefore premise
3 conclusion therefore God does not
exist
the argument is logically valid of
course theists will vehemently deny the
soundness of premise too that's where
the action is so to speak and it means
that theist must offer positive reasons
in which to infer God's existence if
there is no evidence for God from the
old rationally expect there to be
evidence then we are within our
epistemic rights to conclude that God
does not exist and that atheism is true
the affirmative reason for atheism is
tied to a panicly of positive arguments
because of time constraints I can't deal
with all of them I'm going to list the
family of arguments and then I'm going
to provide one specific argument that I
think is quite powerful
the first family of arguments seeks to
demonstrate a logical incoherence in the
very concept of God either because
they're supposed to Divine property off
guard taken on its own is logically
impossible or because some sets of
supposed Divine properties is logically
incompossible
the second family of arguments seeks to
demonstrate that the existence of God is
logically incomposable with the
existence of certain undeniable facts
about the natural world
for example one the existence of
horrendous evil and suffering in the
world or two the existence of
non-resistant non-believers or three the
existence of darksastic Discord and
religious heterogeneity
the third sort of argument is
non-deductive in character and seeks to
demonstrate not that the existence of
God is income possible with these facts
but rather that the existence of God is
a poor explanatory hypothesis when
you're foregoing facts and others
besides are taken into consideration
cumulative consideration
the idea is that on a conspectus of all
the relevant doctor
the naturalistic hypothesis explains the
data better than the theistic hypothesis
it is obvious that if one has a choice
between two competing theories and the
one is better at explaining the relevant
data than it is more rational to accept
that theory
what then constitutes a better Theory or
explanation
I contend that it is one that has the
greatest explanatory scope and death
while also being the most parsimonious
the core idea is that naturalism can
explain all the relevant data at least
as well as theism and it is by its very
nature more parsimonious than abuse
after all theism posits the natural
world plus something more
I could say that nationalism can explain
the existence of the universe so-called
fine-tuning of the universe
Consciousness and morality at least as
well as theism can
furthermore nationalism can better
explain a host of more specific facts
about reality that are not well
explained by the theistic hypothesis for
example I've already alluded to this the
scope distribution quantity of
horrendous suffering in the world
both animal and human to the existence
of non-resistant non-believers through
the existence of darksastic Discord in
the form of widespread religious
heterogeneity and for the continued and
repeated success of naturalistic
explanations in displacing
supernaturalistic Integrations over the
course of human history
turning them to the specific argument
that I'd like to present there are many
more but time constraints only implement
this one
it's the form of The Logical argument
from Evil presented by J.L Schellenberg
and what he calls the new logical
argument from evil challenge JL
Schellenberg explains the central thrust
of this version of argument to be the
following quote feists must rationalize
from God without evil prior to Creation
prior fear may be taken logically or
temporally or in both senses to God with
evil after
no such transitions so it may be argued
is metaphysically possible the key
thought can be put in the form of a
slope in any possible world including
God once purely good always purely good
what we have here is something like the
theological analog of Newton's first law
of motion another way of putting it is
no evil before creation no evil after
the premises of the argument of are as
follows one God is unsurpassedly great
two God is ontologically independent of
any world that he creates
three prior to any world being created
there is no evil in God of any kind
there are only Divine Goods this is the
prior purity of God
therefore for every possible non-divine
good is greatly exceeded by a good of
the same type existing in God prior to
the world
therefore five every worldly good is
greatly exceeded by a good of the same
type existing in God prior to the
creation of the world
[__]
therefore every wealthy good sorry six
all Goods found in God prior to the
world are pure Goods they are Goods with
that exist without any evil whatsoever
seven therefore every worldly good is
greatly exceeded by a pure good of the
same time existing in God prior to the
existence of the world
therefore eight every worldly good that
may commit or acquire evil is greatly
exceeded by a pure good of the same time
existing in God prior to the world
therefore nigh if every worldly good
that commits or requires evil is greatly
exceeded by a pure good of the same type
existing in God prior to the world then
any world containing Goods permitting or
acquiring evil is greatly exceeded by a
new world modeling the corresponding
pure Goods in God
people attend any world containing Goods
permitting or acquiring evil is greatly
exceeded by any world modeling modeling
and corresponding pure Goods in God this
would be a greater world
God can ensure the existence of such
greater worlds and can do so limitlessly
therefore if a any world containing
Goods permitting or requiring evil is
greatly exceeded by a world modeling the
corresponding pure Goods in God and be
the existence of Greater worlds can
limitlessly be insured by God then for
any world X that requires or permits
evil there is some greater worldwide
that models pure goodness in God such
that God has no good reason or
justification to create X rather than
worldwide
for any world X that requires or permits
evil there is some greater worldwide
that models pure goodness in God such
that God has no good reason or
justification to create World X rather
than worldwide
therefore 14. if for any world X that
requires or permits evil there is some
greater worldwide that models pure
goodness in God such that God has no
good reason or justification to create X
rather than why then God has no good
reason or justification to the medieval
in the world
15 therefore God has no good reason or
justification to permit evil in the
world
16. but if there is evil in the world
then God has good reason or
justification to permit evil in the
world Seventeen therefore there is no
evil in the world 18 however as we all
know there is evil in the world
19 the conclusion therefore there is
both evil and not evil in the world
which is a contradiction
[Music]
concludes having derived this
contradiction in the way that we have it
follows that the conjunction of the
three commitments of theism mentioned at
the beginning of the discussion and
surpassable greatness ontological
Independence and prior Purity are
logically consistent with the fourth
undeniable fact they need the existence
of evil in the world
yeah
that's a complete that concludes in
essence my presentation and obviously I
look forward to discussing the merits on
the details of those arguments in the
course guys session thank you very much
[Applause]
um
next as per agreement of the panel we
will hear from Mohamed Egypt
um let me just stop that please start um
let's
Suppose there is no God
[Music]
let's Suppose there is no omniscient one
no omnipotent one no all knowledgeable
one no all powerful one no necessary
being let's suppose no problem
what do we have
what are the explanations that we have
that the Universe came from nothing
but we know from nothing nothing comes
because nothing is the absence of
something
that the universe is self-generated
but we know that that's a contradiction
because the universe cannot generate
itself exists and not exist at the same
time
so what do we know
what do we know we know there existence
a universe we know I exist
we know you exist
we know Oppenheimer exists and things
that exists and hopefully some have been
explosions today
except of the argument
I will say
that when you know that the dependent
existences exist
you have two options either you have a
chain a finite chain a
depends on b or B depends on a c depends
on B
in which case a
is the beginning of that chain we the
Muslims call that the necessary being
the independent one of God
obviously the atheist account subscribe
to that theory
please
so what do we have left we have an
infinite chain
an infinite chain of dependent things
by an infinite chain of dependencies is
an absurd proposition
the reason being
because if this was actualizing the
actual world for example through an
infinite amount of multiverses
then it would imply that the
inexhaustible has been exhausted
the unlimited has been Limited which is
a contradiction she's absurd
it would also imply that infinite sets
exist within internet sets
which means that the part is equivalent
to the whole Butler par is defined by
most neurologists as a portion of the
whole
which is an absurdity itself and a
contradiction
so let's suppose God doesn't exist
what can you a atheists actually present
and put on the table
you've got nothing
and the best is the face I can actually
put to the table is to say naturalism
can explain just as well he says he's
not even trying to say it's better
he's trying for equality he's got a
Nelson Mandela approach to the situation
foreign
because in an intellectual way
we will conclude therefore
that's a necessary being through which
everything depends upon is independent
in and of itself and everything depends
upon is the only way to make sense of
dependent things
you see
contingent things cannot exist within
necessary things like contingent thing
is possible can exist or not exist
a necessary thing is not possible it's
impossible not to exist in other words
contingencies cannot exist within
Necessities the existence of dependent
things the existence of this young man
here the handsome one and Oppenheimer
it's forefathers led to a lot of
people's non-existence
their existence indicates without shadow
of a doubt that unnecessary being is
required
so what kind of necessary being is this
we know I'm Different to him and we know
he's different to him and we know you're
different to him differentiation
indicates possibility and contingency
and wherein there is differences and
possibility and contingency therein
there must be an explanation for this
and what is the explanation for this
Islamic theism says an external sorting
agents
which specify them particularized things
to be a certain manner
which indicates a choice had to be made
and this we would say indicates
a Chooser a Willa which we would say is
the will of God
so already we've identified though you
have to have something which is
independent and necessary post Eternal
and pre-etonal to break away from the
Infinities and have a will
what do we call that we call that got
yes we do and it's the only explanation
that doesn't lead to contradiction and
absurdity I challenge anybody here today
to give me another explanation that
doesn't lead to contradiction and
absurdity
foreign
you see
I finished quite early
I've got more to say
I've got more to say which is okay you
said fine I understand the situation I
agree with you no problem
but why'd you say that Islam is true
before we get there one more
prerequisite must be made
how could there be only one of these how
come there's not three for example in
the trying situation
because if there was an individuating
factor that individuated
and differentiated necessary being a
from necessary being B
that would render either or both of them
contingent
because a contingent thing is
differentiated
in reality
an unnecessary being cannot be
differentiated from something else but
I'll give you an easier argument
which is the quranic arguments
chapter 23 verse 91 that there couldn't
be more than one God effectively because
they would outstriping another in power
there cannot be more than one overall
power
because an all-powerful agent by
definition
Yes means that he has power over all
other things nothing can supervine on
his power capabilities
moreover there cannot be more than one
overall will
Canada
in chapter 21 verse number 22. if there
was in them I either
more than one the heavens and the Earth
would have been corrupt meaning what
yeah you have one overriding will
because it had been more than one will
it wouldn't be consistent
you couldn't explain the uniformity the
regularity the stability of the universe
because there is uniformity stability
and regularity without it you couldn't
even do science
and there is uniformity stability and
regularity to the extent which it allows
life to exist on the universe that's a
fact no one here will deny
there is life on the universe and that
the universe is uniform and regular and
stable enough to allow such life to
exist what is the best explanation for
This One Singular overarching will that
doesn't lead to conflict
so that's why it's one God but what
about the Prophet Muhammad
now there's many things I can say
and in seven minutes
I'll just mention one evidence
the unnecessary and sufficient
conditions
for a word of God to be conceived as
such the word of God
I would put to the table today
not one of these necessary condition
[Music]
s there we're all
the Quran says if this was
many contradictions inside him
the Quran this is one of the necessary
conditions it's one of the only books to
even posit this challenge religious
books
which is kind of contradiction within it
secondly it's inimitable thirdly it's
preserved we will argue all these points
however what's the sufficient condition
I give you one argument and one argument
only
now I'm claiming here and I'm willing to
be challenged today that the Prophecies
of the Prophet Muhammad are those
accurate and numerous and frequent
frequent that comes from an integral
source and unambiguous in human history
these five Criterion
these five Criterion that I've just
mentioned if you apply them to any other
historical figure it will collapse
for example if you look at the Bible
Mark chapter number 13 you'll find that
it says in one generation the heavens
and earth will be destroyed
Nostradamus made a prediction that in
177 years there'll be famine war and so
on the Prophet Muhammad
he made the following predictions for
example I'll give you some
that's the barefooted Arabs
that they will compete to see who
creates the highest buildings
now we're seeing that the highest
building in the world is in Burj Khalifa
how could the economic capabilities of
these nations be such that someone
wanted to argue through the
self-fulfilling prophecy that it was
such
it couldn't be number two that the
prophet sallam predicted the fool the
downfall of the Persian and the Roman
Empire the two greatest empires of that
time spanning millennia not only that
that the Muslims would overtake those
Empires
number three the prophet Muhammad sallam
predicted the invasions of the Mongols
and I'm ready to give all the primary
sources it's very well known in the
Islamic tradition
he told us how the Mongols would invade
and one of the biggest battles in Muslim
history was in general in 1260. the the
the
the the sacking of Baghdad was in 1258
and this is all connected to the
Prophecies of the prophet
the prophet Muhammad sallam told us what
kind of world would be living in he said
the world in the future will be such
that there will be so much interest
whoever doesn't consume the interest he
will be affected by his dust
we living in an economic system the
whole thing is interest women Busters
perpetuated or exacerbated at least by
the intra systems of the banks I think
South Africa is no different
number five the prophet Muhammad told us
that there'll be an advent of sexually
transmitted diseases due to an increased
fornication
the part number six the prophet sallam
told us that woman will go into the
workforce
yes I'm not sure if any of you have
heard this one
this is
involve herself in business with her
husband
this is a prophet a prophetic Hadith
told us about obesity they'll become a
phenomena within his own mind
and many people in this room I only get
it it says you see what I mean
the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam told us exactly where Islam is
going to spread
out he said foreign
look at the map
he told us exactly where Islam was
spread he said he'll go to a sin the
land it will go to India and Pakistan
it's all go to Egypt he told us he will
go to Assam Jordan and Lebanon and these
countries Yemen How could somebody get
this so right there's been no figure in
human history who has predicted with
such frequency and unambiguity the
events of the future
foreign
[Music]
and these are just some examples I could
go on for two hours and books have been
written volumes voluminous books have
been written
encyclopedic compendious voluminous
books have been written on the issue
I'm not going to talk about that today
I've just given you as much as you need
not to respond to my interlocutor
quickly
he's talking about the problem of evil
he had two arguments effectively one of
them was disagreement religious
disagreement
effectively and I don't want a strong
manner to make it correct same with the
existence of religious disagreement
means there's no God
what the hell is this sorry to say
um
and they are in fact continually
disagreeing what is
except for who Allah
and that's the reason why he creates
them in the first place he created you
as a test my friend to see of you which
is going to be good and bad
in line with God's wisdom and mercy
and he says evil the problem of evil
which we've had a thousand times before
I just I disbelieve in evil how about
that I believe evil is privation I don't
believe evil is substratum but even
under a microscope acsw where evil is
evil is privation is the lacking of
God's goodness that's why I say evilness
tell me where evil is let me use
empirical value judgment to show where
the substance of evil is evil doesn't
exist
how about that as an atheist you don't
believe in God but you believe in evil
but you can't put Evil under a
microscope empirically what ontological
status does evil have how can you use
the existence of non-existence to try
and disprove the existence of the
necessary existence
it's a waste of time and we've got 20
seconds here and then that time
and we'll just recycle Quran
which is
the one who everyone depends upon he
depends upon nothing
if that's not nor is it because
there's nothing like it
uh our next families is
well I thought that was a marvelous
place to end off talking about the
question of evil
well
um Aaron has spoken about the arguments
for and against the existence of God I'm
going to talk about why atheists can
talk about the existence of morality and
why they give a better account
now the first place to start is to say
well what would a good moral theory look
like
well firstly we should know what it
requires of us in other words
the theory tells us what we ought to do
in the world what's permissible what's
not permissible
it should cohere with our ordinary
intuitions so if it prohibits things
that we think are good or neutral that's
a problem for the theory
if it allows things that we think are
repugnant or bad that's also a problem
for the theory
it must be consistent the theory mustn't
be at odds with itself it shouldn't
require you to do X and also not X
we also think that it should be
Universal that we can take the moral
theory and we can apply it across
history and across the world and we can
make moral judgments and will tell us
that certain things were wrong even if
people at the time believe them to be
right so for example it was a case that
throughout human history slavery was
practiced a lot of people believed that
slavery was a moral practice and a good
moral theory should tell you that those
people were wrong that slavery is always
wrong and can never be justified that's
what a good moral theory should do
now
um
Hamza has in his book a theistic account
of what Marathi requires of us and what
a good moral theory is and the claim is
really that God is the foundation of
morality
and he takes the Divine command Theory
approach so we say whatever God's
commands that is what's right
now
this is dealt with in what's called you
thyroid dilemma
there's two horns that 11. the first is
is it good because God commands it
or does God command it because it is
good
sorry there's a terrible beeping sound
if someone could turn that off I'd
really appreciate it so the horns of
memories does God command it because it
is good or is it good because God
commands it
now if it's good because God commands it
you run into this arbitriness problem
which is that God could command anything
God could say kill the firstborn and it
would be good because God had commanded
it God could say that the right thing to
do is wear purple underwear on a Tuesday
something we think is neutral and it
would be good because God commands it so
there's the opportunist problem
if you take the other Horn of the
Dilemma which is that God knows what is
good and therefore that's why he
commands it
then the foundation of morality doesn't
stem from God's commands but it's
external to God
now in his book comes a text another
move to say well actually there's a
third option
which is to say that God's nature is
good
and that's why whatever stems from God's
commands is good the problem with this
approach is that really it just moves
the problem one step back so we can ask
are the things that are in God's nature
good because they're in God's nature or
are they good because of an external
standard so God could have a series of
character traits God could be vicious
and spiteful and jealous
and we'd say Well they're in God's God's
nature therefore they're good and that
would of course not go here with our
ordinary sense of what goodness is or we
could say God has a series of attributes
that match our external stands of
goodness
so relocating the problem to God's
nature doesn't get you out of this
so what does Secular ethics have to
offer
well the atheist has a number of
different approaches they're not
necessarily required to believe in one
particular ethical system there's a
variety that are available to them I'm
going to give you a couple that I think
are very plausible
so the first one is grounded in the idea
that we all suffer
that suffering is something that all of
us have experienced that when we see
suffering we think that it is lamentable
and bad that we try to prevent suffering
that we ought not to go and collect
suffering upon others
and I think that there's a very good
moral theory that can come out of that
in other words we think that if you were
to pull out a baby's eyeballs just for
the fun of it and cause the baby to
suffer
we don't need to ask why that's wrong we
know innately that suffering is a bad
thing
we might think that the morality
supervenes upon the fact of the
suffering and that is a good reason not
to do that to the baby and that no
matter which deity commanded you to go
and pull the eyeballs out of the baby it
would be wrong
another account that you can have is
grounded in the nature of beings
so uh variety can extend not just the
humans but to animals animals we know
can suffer for example we might have
obligations to animals Not to cause
neither suffrage them do we think about
humans for a minute the humans have this
capacity for rationality
that you can reason through various
ideas and because of that you can create
what Emmanuel can calls universal laws
so One path to Second morality is in the
categorical imperative where Khan says
will a law that if universalized you
would be able to operate upon
so the idea is can I will that it's okay
to lie to someone in order to extract
money from them and he says well imagine
a world in which everybody lied
I'm just so probably gonna stop for um
so we're trying to
it seems like it's finally offline
um
foreign
[Music]
well as a demonstration of my point that
suffering is bad
so that's our first secular account that
the presence of suffering is bad it is
an evil and condemnable and you can
build a moral theory based on the
presence of suffering that you ought not
to call it to other people that you
ought to try and alleviate it when you
see it and thank you so much for
alleviating that suffering that we've
all been enduring for the last 10
minutes
here's a second account that you can
have which is sourced internationality
so Emmanuel [__] comes up with the
categorical imperative so the idea is
that there are universal laws that can
guide us that tell us what we ought to
do and what we ought not to do so for
example if you have the maxim that it is
okay to lie to someone in order to cheat
them out of money
Khan says well you need to universalize
the maxim so imagine a world in which
everybody lies everybody else in order
to deceive them into handing over money
what would happen in Sasha world no one
would believe each other nor to hand
over the money so the maxim would fail
so just through the process of
rationality you can see that you cannot
will such a law into existence which is
that it's okay to lie in order to
extract money
John Rawls has a contemporary account of
how you can Source morality so imagine
this case you're relying in a hospital
bed
you're covered head to toe in Damages
and you've got quite a severe case of
Amnesia so you can't recall your sex
your race your faith but you have a
basic understanding of economics and
history doctor walks into the room and
he says I'm going to give you a once in
a lifetime opportunity I'm going to let
you set the rules for the world that you
step into but you've got to set the
rules first before I take off the
bandages
and so you think I need to act in my own
self-interest
so what if I introduce the rule that men
have more power than women or their
whites or to get more property than
blacks
well maybe if I check if the bandages
I'll wind up being a black woman
so I wouldn't produce such a rule and so
he thinks under this veil of ignorance
that you will then generate a set of
rules that we track Common Sense
morality so there you have three
different secular accounts rather don't
require the existence of God that I
think meet those criteria quite well in
terms of what is a good moral theory
they're consistent that you're here with
our intuitions
and there's an advantage as well in that
you can make adjustments if you are
dealing with something divine
the idea is that the text that was
granted to us is immutable
that if it says things which no longer
cohere with our common sense intuitions
we either have to try and pretend that
they're not there we have to try and
interpret our way out of them but we're
Bound by the text and at some point it
starts to look audacious when you're
trying to talk around some things that
are clear in the text
the secular Theory says well we were
mistaken in the past that our moral
theory wasn't very good let's make some
adjustments so you find for example that
the growth of moral theories to be more
inclusive to say that our obligations to
others extend not just the people with
particular Sexes or faiths or religions
but to everybody if we have this of
growing egalitarianism
so now I've given you those accounts and
I'm going to talk about some particular
moral requirements in the Quran but
first I just like it if that door could
be closed because it's very loud again
please close the door and not talk thank
you
thank you again you can see the presence
of suffering is an evil
so I'm going to give you a couple of
examples of sharia law and I'm open to
um in the conversation if I've gotten
anything wrong or if I've given a bad
account of the law please correct me
let's start with the idea of being an
apostate the idea that if you're a
Muslim that you have an obligation to
stay in the faith and not leave the
faith and not to rebuke the faith
now one of the most well-known apostates
or those accused of being in the past Ed
was someone rushed him Rushdie wrote the
book Hispanic verses
in 1989 it's a enormously popular
bestseller and I think most people are
aware of the facts that the Ayatollah
Khomeini issued a fatwa illegal opinion
saying that because of the Blasphemous
content in the book and because of the
fact that he was a Muslim that it is the
obligation of all Muslims when they see
him to kill him
um and I'm going to read just a little
short extract
from that fatwa
we are from Allah and to Allah we shall
return I'm informing all Brave Muslims
of the world that the author the
systemic verses are text written edited
and published against Islam the prophet
of Islam and the Quran along with all
the editors and Publishers aware of its
contents are condemned to death
I call on all Berlin Muslims wherever
they may be in the world to kill them
without delay
so that no one will will dare insult the
sacred beliefs of Muslims henceforth and
whoever is killed in this cause will be
a matter Allah willing meanwhile if
someone has access to the author of the
book but is incapable of carrying out
the execution he should inform the
people so that richly is punished for
his actions
now the source
um in the Quran for this view
was in chapter 9 verse 61
some of them heard the Prophet by saying
here's all he is say it is better for
you that he listens to you he believes
in God and trusts the Believers he has a
mercy for those among you who believe
those who hurt God's messenger have
incurred a painful retribution
now there is some debate in the
community about whether or not this was
a legitimately issued uh penalty whether
there should have been a trial
we know that rishti was driven to hiding
for many many years up until last year
when he gave a talk in America and while
giving the talk was publicly attacked on
stage and his eye was garged up
so I invite my friends to deal with this
question is it wrong to be an apostate
was the punishment fitting it seems that
that doesn't cohere with our ordinary
requirements of moral philosophy in
other words The Atheist would never
punish someone who ceased to be an
atheist who became a Believer a
polytheist or a theist of any sort
we can then think about
um the the publication Charlie hebdo
um so many of the writers and
cartoonists of their publication in
France were violently executed on the
grounds that they had produced
depictions of the Prophet Muhammad now
again there's some debate as to whether
or not it is permissible at all to
produce such depictions but it seems
that if there is such a rule it can only
bind Believers in the faith
um and to say that those who have
reached the rule of our non-believers
deserve death uh strikes me as contrary
to our ordinary moral intuitions
now what is the Quran say about people
who are non-believers
well in chapter 5 verse 10 says as the
as for those who just believe in denial
science they are the Resonance of the
Hellfire
as for disbelievers even if they were to
possess everything in the world Trice
over and offer to Ransom themselves from
the punishment of the day of judgment it
would never be accepted from them and
they will suffer a painful punishment
they will be desperate to get out of the
fire but they'll never be able to they
will suffer an everlasting punishment
and to those who say Allah is one in
eternity in other words Christians have
certainly Fallen to disbelief there is
only one God if they do not stop saying
this those who disbelieve among them
will be afflicted with the painful
punishment
now
again it seems odd to think that you
have you should have eternal Hellfire
Eternal suffering for failure to believe
in a particular God no secular religion
would no secular Viewpoint would ever
require this
I also think that punishments ought to
fit crimes so that there ought to be a
level of proportionality
and that there is a failing in this
regard
so
Chapter 5 Verse 33 says the penalty for
those who watch wage war against the
lion is messenger and spread Mischief in
the land is death crucifixion cutting
off their hands and feet on opposite
sides or Exile from the land there's
penalties that are great the disgrace
for them in this world and they will
suffer tremendous punishment in the
hereafter
the commentary says that in the case of
armed robbery offenders right hands and
left feet are to be cut off
now there are some circumscribed ways in
which these penalties will be imposed
that you should have people who can
testify you can prove it uh what the
things you might expect in a court of
law but I would think that no moral
court system would impose your hands
being cut off for the crime of theft we
can all accept that theft is wrong but
it must be proportional punishment in
other words maybe you think of custodial
sentence maybe you think are fine but
having your hands removed seems
disproportionate
now with regards to sexual ethics
um
there are some further problems
chapter 24 2 says
as for female and male fornicators give
each of them 100 lashes and do not let
pity for them to make you lenient in
enforcing the law of Allah if you truly
believe in the land the last day that a
number of Believers witnessed their
punishment
now
what about having sex with a woman while
she's menstruating
the commentary on it's 4 16.
says that one who goes into a woman in
menstruation or anus or goes to a
soothsay and accepts his statement
remains an unknown then such people have
rejected what is revealed to Muhammad as
for a fixed punishment for this evil act
there is a difference of opinions among
Muslim jurors details of which are
available in the books of Vic
nevertheless the nature of such
punishments reported by them is as
severe as it can be such as burning into
fire
bashing under a wall felt over throwing
down from a height stoning and beheading
with the sword
now what about homosexuality well again
this is condemned
and the idea is that it is deserving of
death
now it's not just theoretically
deserving of death that it is practiced
in a number of countries that have
Sharia law
that gay people are executed
now one line is to say well it's okay to
be gay we just have a problem with the
act of homosexuality
but a secular accountant morality is
going to say well have you caused anyone
to suffer by engaging in a consensual
Act of homosexual sex no have you
violated any rights
no
if you were to sit in the bell of
ignorance and imagine that you yourself
may very well be a homosexual who would
like to have loving relationships and
sex with others would you want such a
rule that would impose the death penalty
upon you no
so there is a difficulty in that
the actual moral views that are
expressed in the Quran
don't meet what we require of a good
moral theory
that there are out of accordance with
our intuitions that they're
non-revisable because the claim is that
they come from a Divine source and that
secular morality provides us with a much
better richer account that can be
claimed to be metaphysically true during
multiple range of sources either through
the presence of suffering it strikes me
as a very interesting move that my
friend has made to say there is no evil
in the world
I would imagine that uh spending some
time being tied up and tortured to death
you would very quickly think there is
evil in the world and I'd like to resist
it to claim that there is no evil is
such an outlandish claim it's said to be
entirely amoral
um and I think not in coherence with our
ordinary intuitions about the nature of
reality but I look forward to a robust
discussion I run the channel uh Brandon
Adventures the philosophy discussion
Channel with Jason weblov and the nature
of our show is such that we try to
engage each other in a polite civil way
so that we can both find out what's
actually true thank you very much
thank you a final esteemed panelist is
uh Hamza Jordan
[Music]
is
May the peace and blessings of Allah be
upon every single one of you
so before I get into my argument for
God's existence that undermines
naturalism which goes against the idea
that naturalism explains reality
and by the way naturalism cannot explain
the hard problem of Consciousness the
acquisition of language objective moral
values and there's a whole list of
recultural facts against the
naturalistic Paradigm to say they
explain the whole of reality is is quite
bizarre but notwithstanding I like to
just make a few points we're going to
address every single one of your
assertions but the first part I'd like
to say is with regards to the problem of
evil argument it's a totally false
argument it misrepresents Islamic theism
because it assumes that evil has some
kind of ontological reality evil is real
from the perspective of that it exists
in our world but ontologically is based
on the goodness and wisdom of the Divine
which undermines some key premises of
that argument also from the perspective
of suffering under naturalistic
accountable what is suffering there's
electrons whizzing around cold blind no
electrons whizzing around
so from a naturalistic paradigm just
like what Richard Dawkins says and I
have respect for him on this particular
on this particular matter because he's
consistent in his book he says it's
pitless indifference no good no evil
also you've strawed man my argument
concerning you through those dilemma I
didn't say God is only good I said God
is good but the way we argue that
because he's the
only deity worthy of worship and the
only deity way to worship is the highest
form of good which we can unpack but
also we have another argument against
you FIFA's dilemma it is a fourth
dilemma because there is no external
standard that Allah has to submit to and
although it is good because God
commanded it his commands are not
arbitrary they're not dislocated away
from his nature that's a false
assumption and also when we look at the
reality of God's commands we see they
cannot be arbitrary unless you want to
believe that something could come from
nothing or something well designed is
actually based on some kind of
Randomness and let me explain God's
commands manifested in Islamic moral and
legal law addresses the moral needs of
human beings on a pestle social and
political level we have over a thousand
heat years of a Great Society secularism
has only existed for what 90 years or
100 years maybe more and we've seen more
Bloodshed on the secularism than any
other moment time and phase in history
but not withstanding the commands of God
I I like a key that perfectly fit in a
lock that opens the door to well-being
and functioning for individuals and
social harmony a key is designed for a
lock and just like the keys designed for
a look the commands of God God are
designed for our well-being therefore is
completely irrational and absurd to
claim that God's commands are arbitrary
to argue that they are arbitrary is
equivalent of claiming that specific key
that opens a specific door was actually
not designed for that function so
there's much more to say so much things
were going on but let me start with what
I call the quranic argument of Prior
cognitive information and today my dear
brothers and sisters and friends all
argue that Islamic these and make sense
of our ability to produce full and
rational judgments I would argue that
the very fact that atheists are
interlocutors can have a full can have a
judgment whether it's sound or not and
there's been very unsound reasoning
going on today but the point is the very
fact that you can have a Thor and you
can have a judgment
[Applause]
requires God's existence in the first
place so it's quite interesting that
atheisms these atheists think about
denying God but that very cognitive
process requires God in the first place
and if I have time I'm going to talk
about why God is worthy of worship and
this argument is from the Quran and the
best arguments are from the Quran if you
go to chapter 2 verses 30 to 33 Allah
says he taught Adam the names of things
then he presented them to the angels and
said tell me the names of these if what
you say is true they replied glory be to
you you have no knowledge except what
you taught us you are truly the
all-knowing the wise Allah says Allah
said or Adam inform them of their names
then when Adam did Allah said did I not
tell you that I know the secrets of the
heavens and the Earth and I know what
you reveal and what you conceal and the
exegetical understanding of this is not
just names but it's Concepts Natures
realities and properties of things so
here's the argument by the way this
argument has been taken from my friend
and my teacher Dr saffron chowder he's a
well-known academic and he actually
published a paper on this particular
topic so here are the premises number
one prior cognitive information is
necessary for humans to formulate
judgments judgments about things number
two the ultimate source of Pride
cognitive information is either from a
human a non-human animal and inanimate
object natural selection chance or a
non-natural source number three the
ultimate source of Pride cognitive
information cannot be from a human a
non-human animal an inanimate object
natural selectional Chance full which is
the conclusion it must be from a natural
source and we have two more conclusions
five the most plausible non-natural
source for prior cognitive information
must be a Transcendent age of cause that
has the property of omniscience life and
intelligence and it finally follows
conclusion six the non-natural agent
pulls in five and we just mentioned
makes sense of the god of Islamic theism
now here's some memory points the
argument that I'm producing today is not
claiming that necessarily at every
historical stage of human development
that it requires some kind of
Supernatural pedagogical agent I'm
saying that the original human the
original human required that Pride
cognitive input and this is very
important it's like a causal argument a
first causal argument from a prior
cognitive input perspective also the
premises that have unpacked they're not
kind of
something that nachos would necessarily
disagree with because we even have in
the empiricist and nativist debate and
discussion of kind of an innate
cognitive apparatus with some kind of
linguistic cognitive biases now even the
empiricists agree that you do require
some nativism but they're not as extreme
if you like as the nativists themselves
also and just to repeat we're talking
about the initial human being requiring
that pedagogical source that gave the
prior cognitive information that is
required for us to have judgments and
thoughts so let's go back to premise one
to unpack prior cognitive information is
necessary for human beings to formulate
judgments about things now the capacity
to think the capacitor of thoughts and
to have rational judgments or unsound
and sound judgments you require at least
four conditions a reality external to
the agent or a perceived reality number
two sense faculties that sense the
reality number three a property
functioning brain that differentiates
the sensuality and for prior cognitive
information if any of these conditions
are absent you cannot have thought you
cannot have judgment
and also you you have to have pride
coming to information in some sense to
be able to link that private cognitive
information to that sense reality in
order to have a thought and a judgment
without that all you're going to have is
sensation and sensation and sensation
you're not going to have thought or any
form of judgment and could and an
adequate cognition and we can unpack
that in the Q a premise number two the
ultimate source of Prior cognitive
information is either from a human
non-human animal in animal object charts
natural selection or non-natural source
so let's go to human beings well the
pride current information that is
necessary for thinking could not have
come ultimately from another human being
why because we could ask where did that
human being get that prior computed
information from and to continue that
chain you have an absurdity of an
infinite regress
non-human animals well we'll be
hard-pressed to give examples of an
intelligent account of how a non-human
animal species could have meaningfully
interacted with human beings based on
some pedagogical setup or approach it
might exist in the future with some
postmodern secular ethics we'll be
marrying animals soon that's what
happens when you change your ethics
based on your own desires and your first
understanding your suffering but the
point is
we don't have that set up at the moment
and God forbid it happens in the future
and if it weren't true that some kind of
animal gave us that Pride cognitive
information or input or at the end of
the day it goes back to the rigorous
problem where did that animal get that
prior cognitive information from and we
know that the infinite regress is absurd
therefore this is an advocate
explanation what about in animal objects
well inanimate objects do not have
cognitive abilities or functions or the
ability to teach instructor passed on
cognitive information just like under
naturalism you kind of play
quickly explain language development you
can't adequately explain the fact that
with inner subjective conscious
experiences because fundamentally under
this physicalist reality it's just blind
cold non-intentional processes and at
the end of the day when you have blind
code non-intentional processes you have
to now start to explain how we could
develop language how we could develop
cognition how we could develop inner
subjective conscious experience and that
is going to be interesting debate
so animal objects fail what about four
charts but let's say doctors have for
children because he actually gives a
beautiful undercutting defeater to this
possibility he says
major problem with this possibility is
that he's not remotely clear how a child
can do anything charge is not
metaphysically a thing an entity it has
no being and it's not recognizing
potency or power it is a term that is
inadvertently endowed with the creative
power of efficacy in fact for a chance
to be a candidate for inputting prior
cognitive information would be to grow
to Grant an all-pervasive power reserved
only for something that would that we
would described as living to do this
however is to commit the fallacy of
verification which consists of
attributing concrete characteristics to
something non-concrete or abstract by
arguing that chance did X created why
and selected Zed obscures something
deeply taking place and that is making
chance of cause when it is mere
mathematical possibilities and
abstractal in effect to attribute
chances and calls for originating Pride
completed information is tantamount to
saying nothing originated prior
cognitive information what about natural
selection well this fails because there
is no necessary link between survival
reproduction and the ability to even
have thoughts and sound or unsound
judgments look at cockroaches
they survive they reproduce for the
right here they're not here talking
about the inner dimensions of
spirituality or theism and Atheism or
debating about moral theory cockroaches
are just cockroaches and unfortunately
we do have the human cockroaches in the
world that cause a lot of suffering and
unfortunately many of them have been
naturalists and secularists but
nevertheless and one would also argue
that there is no necessary link between
Survivor production even having true
Reliable Property faculties for example
if I'm a the first human or I'm part of
the evolutionary chain and one of your
ancestors that walk into a jungle and I
have the false belief based on the
unreliable cognitive faculties that
mushrooms are poisonous I'm gonna
survive but is it true that all
mushrooms are poisonous of course not
now the atheists May report and say what
about evolutionary libelism this is the
view that is more likely for natural
selection to select traits that formed
cognitive faculties that were reliable
and produce true beliefs over unreliable
cognitive faculties that produce false
beliefs however I will reply by saying
where's your evidence why the epistemic
privilege why and when you look at the
empirical evidence with all due respect
you have to be radical Skeptics and
therefore there is no truth the claim
there is no God they claim that there is
evil you have to be radical skeptic
skept you have to be radical skeptical
about these categories in actual fact
you have to turn into a post-modernist
now the reason I'm saying this because
when you look at the works of James sage
and many others and you look at
cognitive science today they're saying
that having true empirical perceptions
is not conducive to Survivor in
production so we have to have false
perceptions or not totally accurate
perceptions also the very fact that you
think that you have to have true beliefs
that are reliable and we will develop
that way and selective forces
wanted selected those traits is to
completely incoherent why because of the
fact that when you use your brain to a
certain degree it drains your resources
to make specific inferences and
deductions drains your biological
resources in action fact it's more
conducive to Survivor and reproduction
to do what to make false generalizations
that would facilitate Survivor
production because like James stage much
later so
conclusion number four therefore it must
be from something non-natural since all
the possible naturalistic explanations
to explain prior cooking information
fail the reasonable conclusion is that
to explain prior cognitive information
is to cite a non-naturalistic
explanation and the non-natural
explanation and this is the conclusion
five and six is that it has to be a
non-natural Transcendent agent that has
the property of omniscience life and
intelligence why must it be living
because an animal object does not
contain prior cognitive information and
it doesn't have the ability to instruct
the prior cognitive information and a
living being is a rational precondition
for possessing any pedagogical
attributes as Allah says Allah there is
no deity except him the ever living in
chapter 2 255.
it must be Transcendent why because as a
transgender regress otherwise would also
require private companies information as
Allah says
in chapter 41 verse 11 there is nothing
like him also he must be willing because
this means it must be a kind of being
that chooses what he wants to do so he
can willingly select the priority
information relevant to and necessary
for human cognitive success or any other
functional objective and a choice
indicates a will as Allah says in the
Quran in chapter 76 verse 30 but you
cannot will to do so unless Allah wills
and finally it must be omniscient this
living willing Transcendent agent cause
must possess immense immense knowledge
to endow it into other intelligent
bearing agents it must also consciously
select all relevant initial cognitive
import and justify that selection
surely Allah is all knowing all aware in
chapter 31 verse 34 and this makes sense
of the traditional God in theism in
general and also Islamic theism and
finally conclude atheism cannot
even start to explain the fact that we
can think have thoughts and judgments
they don't have the key to open the door
to rationality why because atheism as
philosophical naturalism has already
been dealt with in this presentation
atheism is a form of revolutionary
relied reliableism has been dealt with
in in this presentation atheism is a
form of scientism has also been dealt
with in the presentation because
naturalist selection fails atheism is a
form of post-modernism where post-modern
principle of knowledge of knowledge
there is no method to come to an
objective truth therefore truth there is
no truth is radically skeptical so you
can't even explain Truth for judgments
itself atheism is a priori that oh is a
priori it's a fifth principle it's a
metaphysic we start with the fact that
we trust our reliable cognitive equities
we say they're reliable well if you're
gonna play that game the door swings
both ways Islam's truths are a PRI too
but but what would you rather choose as
a rational agent a comprehensive
explanation of reality that explains
your your your your ability to form
judgments
and you could claim that as a priori or
another so-called a priori that can't
even explain our ability to think and
form judgments so brothers and sisters
and friends atheism is a failed project
in every shape and form all
manifestations of atheism it can't even
explain our ability to have cognition to
think to form rational judgments and at
the end of the day the atheists and
physicalist universe just reduces the
human being to Blind cold
non-intentional physical processes and
it's all pitless indifference and I
would suggest diatological tools become
more consistent and coherent with the
world's View and just say there is no
good there is no evil there is
why is truth a valued because in the
empirical world it's all valueless
anyway electrons whizzing around thank
you very much
okay so what we're doing now is we're
going into the panelists
discuss amongst themselves it's going to
be an open internal discussion uh we
lost quite a bit of time uh we'll we'll
try
um to go 20 minutes and see how it goes
but then I want to bring in our two
discussions and just add you two to the
discussion uh and we'll hopefully have a
good um uh fire started and then we were
bringing you as the audience for the
final 15 minutes or so that um open
discussion
um so I'm not sure how you want to
proceed I have questions as well uh in
fact let me just say say some give you
some thoughts that came to mind
um
it seems uh
uh seems uh uh that uh Hamza that you're
the argument you gave there uh is trying
to undercut the AC project uh and I've
heard I've heard this sort of argument
um before in fact I'm working on on
things similar and not even in a
theological setting but you are you're
talking about the
um
what would you call it uh evolutionary
argument against naturalism
um yeah that's plenty Goose form but
this is not the same yeah that's the
name I was looking for
um which is the idea that that
nationalism is self-defeating but
there's something something quite
interesting there
um uh I'm wrestling with this as an
emphasis as well what is grounding
ethics yes uh so I'm trained in in the
the Western analytic tradition
um uh and um I'm trying to figure out
okay why are these moves being made uh
and I you know my sense is that these
specific moves will be made inside the
ontology and and uh consequentialism are
they being made because uh let's say the
old way the the religious way of
grounding ethics has been jettisoned
um and now there needs to be a new
starting point and and what you're
suggesting is that that starting point
uh will be based on on faith either way
um but you suggesting that this this
basis has uh first it has um it has uh
uh let's say uh centuries of religious
grounding to it
um whereas the the new uh the new
attempt to Ground Post religion
post-date of God has an arbitrator in
this to it that needs to be recognized I
I don't miss a represent what you're
saying
um but I find that quite intriguing
because
um
I'm not sure
um I'm not sure what uh resources there
might be to
uh grapple with what you're saying
without accepting
um the ontology under eyes what do you
think and this is not just a problem for
today's discussion it's a problem for
philosophy in general of course there's
a there's a problem of uh of uh
different ontologies competing with each
other
um and this is this is actually
something for all of you
um one of my uh I would say concerns
coming into the room
um that we recognize that there are
different anthologies and different
cosmologies right
I hope that I'm uh multilingual in the
sense that I understand ontology or
underwriting your views and I'm I I can
understand the ontology underwriting
areas but I think it's the first step we
first have to realize that there are
these different ontologies
can we can I just talk here because you
spent three minutes making that point
and we've got 25 minutes for the segment
and I just want to say that when you're
talking about morality and you're
talking about Sharia law and all these
kinds of things you mentioned something
quite interesting he said our ordinary
requirements for moral philosophy you
mentioned as well like you've got
deontological ethics you've got
consequentialism or teleological effects
pick up a book on ethics like for
example John Mackey you're going to find
this kind of classification this is a
western classification you mentioned two
men which are Emmanuel Khan and John
rules both of which in a sense represent
the white liberal tradition both white
men from Western from the Western
Hemisphere my question is why should it
be that white men dictate to us what
morality is have we had enough of this
in this country in a sense that you know
this is now to be honest with you in a
veiled sense if you set our requirements
for Morality this is all subscribed to
it we have a completely different
understanding in a completely different
ontology why have you assumed that the
white man is right what proof that you
have that is it manual categorical
imperative or it's hypothetical
imperative or John rules veil of
ignorance what you get mentioning any of
that stuff is true and if it what proof
do you have it's objectively truth as an
atheist if we can get through this
question then we can talk about Sharia
law and the false things that you were
saying about it for example a woman
that's menstruating gets burnt or
something like that you get burned by it
or if you're if you have sex with the
one that's menstruating we should not
mention in any book of in Islam
whatsoever and you mentioned this
mention the book so Philip it's not
mentioned in any book whatsoever then
you mentioned Khomeini who was an
obscure figure so my question is as an
atheist you you're you have the audacity
to say our requirements of moral
philosophy as if the white man's moral
philosophy is all of our moral
philosophies no we have Divine command
Theory we have Quran we have Sunnah we
have our own way of deriving morals
what objective proof do you to have the
deontological ethics of Emmanuel Kant
and all the veil of ignorance of John
rules who is a liberal both of them are
liberal in a sense and or any of the
consequentialist ethics of any of the
utilitarian thinkers of the Monday is
objectively true so first of all I think
you play a very dangerous game when you
attach second ethics to race and you rob
people who are of many races of their
human rights like when you say that it's
a white man's game
to talk about rice not what you're
trying to bother suffering no I didn't
say it's a white man's race games
talking about rights I said that what
you've mentioned is a western form of
Ethics is the ones who the knowledge
producers were objectively white men
objectively from the liberal tradition
in Europe you'll know about the genetic
fallacy I'm not saying it's false I'm
asking you why it's true yes so let's
first I just first I want to deal with
this question of people saying we can
assess the content of the ideas by
looking at the race and the sex of the
speaker you said our moral philosophy
you've included me in your morality I'm
asking you to prove your morality before
you say Alma I don't subscribe to a
morality answer me why is the veil of
ignorance of Jordan rules or the
consequentialist moralities of any of
the liberal thinkers or the veil of
ignorant or the the ontological ethics
of that it's true I'll get to it you're
gonna have to stop interacting yeah okay
so first to add to you so it enhances
your discourse you also mentioned rights
yes if you don't mind I'm assuming
you're advocating a liberal conception
of writing the universal Declaration of
Human Rights
well do you Advocate the UN the claim
that I've made is that there are three
different ways in which an atheist can
construct morality
because you mentioned rights twice yeah
and it's very important to the
ontological account can get you right
and the consequences the car can also
get you right but from the perspective
of law of legal and more reasoning and
what your views are so I understand how
to deal with you yeah and your beliefs
in a positive way what conception of
rights do you Advocate is it is it the
conception of rights that is known as
the universal uh Declaration of Human
Rights so first of all I haven't
expressed the personal view about ethics
and I don't intend I'm doing it okay you
mentioned rights twice could you say
very nice
buttons are connected to morality you've
asked him a number of questions can you
just take the discussion
just one to ten minutes I do a project I
just wanted to add to that because uh
that's going to be a follow-up question
so if you think about that just let us
know yeah because what I want you to say
was that has a liberal individualist
assumption which many people don't have
to uh agree and that's why when you come
to the table with these universals it
does come across in some way that
there's a sign of maybe superiority
complex and I don't mean it in the
negative way I'm just trying to
psychoanalyze certain statements in a
positive way so we know and you could
stand in the possibility in actual fact
that you may think you're already right
and I want you to stand the possibility
that you might be wrong and if that's
the case then maybe Define your terms a
bit more clearer clearly clearer clearer
especially when you're mentioning things
like rights because rights is a big term
but it has ideological strong constructs
that's my point all right so I'm not
going to speak without interruption
absolutely and I'm going to try and
answer your questions please please
you're still interrupting me that's okay
so all right let's first of all talk
about the different raw Frameworks that
you can have I haven't picked a lane for
myself and I don't intend on doing so
the claim that I have made
is that an atheist is entitled to claim
that there are moral facts that they
don't have to buy the nihilism you've
set up a false dilemma which is to say
that either morality is grounded in God
or there is no such thing as morality
that the atheist is required to say that
they're just whizzing atoms and they
can't have any normative force and what
I pointed out is that there are very
good secular claims to why there is
morality either grounded in suffering or
grounded in human reason which can
generate rights and by the way those
rights can be spoken about either in
legal instruments so we can talk about
rights that are allocated by the UN or
they can just be talked about in the
deontological sense you don't
necessarily have to think that the UN
Chancellor and human right is the
definitive account
um but I think we think a lot of the
rights that are in the charter are
pretty good now you can bite the bullet
you can just say I don't buy any of it I
don't believe in rice I don't think
there's a problem with suffering I don't
like any of the rules that the rules
generates
and you can just buy bullets and you can
say there is nothing wrong with putting
homosexuals to death
um that's just your white liberal
Western conception of things and then
we're gonna have to agree to disagree on
it
the point is that you have to buy
Superior apartment bullets
that when you deny the major moral
theories
that's the consensus is going to be
against you now it has nothing to do
with your race or your sex
while I was trying to explain this that
there's a huge danger in claiming that
the liberal tradition or that the moral
philosophies that have emanated from
John Stewart tomorrow John rules where
Emmanuel County belong to white people
or because they're imminent from white
people there's something wrong with them
first of all many people around the
world benefit from the notion of Human
Rights the idea that as an individual
you have a claim against someone else
not to do certain things to you that
because you have a right to dignity it
is wrong for someone to intentionally
torture you against your will to put you
into a status of slavery I mean one of
the examples that I gave where I said
any person who thinks that
um variety is external and a good thing
would think that slavery is a bond now
the Quran mentions slavery on many
occasions
if the Quran mentions slavery and we'd
expect the Divine being that either
issues good commands or is aware of what
is good to not just have regulation of
our state but to outright condemn it to
say that no matter the society that
you're in regardless of the place or the
time slavery is always wrong and we just
don't see that in the crowd that seems
like a failure that's responding
you've completely miscategorized what he
said you've straw man actually what he
said which is very surprising
considering your level of qualification
and education I'm actually surprised
that he didn't say we don't believe in
rights or suffering he said we don't
believe in opportunity that you can't
prove it objectively underline the word
objectively as an atheist there is no
mechanism through which you can prove
deontological ethics or consequentialist
ethics on an objective framework which
is why John Stuart Mill tried to prove
that desirability principle in his book
on utilitarianism what I'm saying is
that this is the first thing you're
gonna have to choose the second thing is
we talk about racing you talk about
slavery let me tell you something
important
okay the prophet said there's no virtue
over a black man over a white man or an
Arab of a non-arab how comes it took you
I don't know how many years has the
white dominance to figure that out only
30 years ago you you stopped a part-time
so why should we listen to you in a
sense okay you're playing the most
Superior Target what would you respect
but what you respect it took you a
thousand three hundred years after the
fact to realize that something the
prophet said Prophet Muhammad who you're
attacking the religion of right now a
three 1 300 years before you now agree
with him so how do we know you're not
going to defound these issues number two
on the issue of slavery okay because you
know when was the one with the departure
then 99 form 30 years ago and they're
telling us about this and that I don't
see how this is working here number two
you said you said this uh the emanation
and the knowledge production of these
ideologies that you're talking about is
undoubtedly white and European you
cannot take that away from the reality
uh I don't think Jon Stewart Mill or
Jeremy Bentham or Emmanuel Kant was
Nigerian I didn't know I didn't see
you're talking about secular ethics it's
not the secular ethics of the black man
is it it's the secular ethics of the
white man and you've already assumed it
to be true just like many of probably
the people before in this country white
men assume the apartheid was true then
then they had to add the suffering by
the way that Mandela and others had to
uh undergo the suffering that which is
good suffering by the way if it's not
all suffering is bad you said suffering
is bad about the suffering that Mandela
and the others the anti-apartheid
activists had to go through was that
good suffering or bad suffering it was
good suffering because then people
realize that it's you know it's equality
and race and it seems like that so this
is what you're doing here is you're
being morally sanctimonious you're
clearly trying to come with a hierarchy
as you explain to me no you explained to
me why your morale is true in the first
place I believe yes homosexuality is
prohibited in Islam it's wrong yes I
believe you're going to go to the
Hellfire if you don't believe in Allah
yes I believe that there's Heaven yes I
believe in day of judgment these are
things I believe in that's tell me why
that's wrong tell me why that makes
Islam to be true what credible
disproving implications does it have as
a philosopher where is your objective
morality where is your objective
reasoning what are the arguments where's
the empiricism where is the calculation
where is the proof where's the evidence
that's why I'm asking don't assume
because the dominance remains in the
Western Hemisphere and there's hegemony
on the side of the Western Hemisphere
that whatever ideology they decide to
put down we're going to assume it's
going to be true that you're going to
come here and tell us our requirements
for moral our moral Partners that's your
moral requirements I have a different
you have a religion I have a different
religion prove to me that no religion is
true that's why I'm saying why is
consequentialism true why is the
ontological ethics true why don't you
come and start with that
before Mark response I just want to make
America comment about the style of
communication
very uncomfortable okay I'm very
uncomfortable with how this is very
quickly degenerated into a shouting
match I understood and I was led to
believe by the organizers of the city
that we were going to be here to discuss
in a mature and reflective way various
World Views I'm very disheartened by the
term that this has already taken so I
want that noted for everybody to see
because because
[Applause]
as philosophers as intellectuals and for
the last five minutes Mark who is out
he's an absolute gentleman has been
shouted at now it's not this relevant to
be honest with you right we're talking
about God and morality you've spoken for
about 10 minutes
can you get to the point please and
again the point is
yeah but it's not really sorry
okay so I want to reset things and I
want to talk about something I'm gonna
say one thing that came out I will date
you I promise I'll let you
um so we did say that this is a
discussion
um and
um we all came here one day to discuss
things and understand that things are
heated I should say that I enjoyed all
four uh presentations I was impressed
with the level of philosophy in all
three or four sorry I said okay all four
presentations right
um and I'd like us
um as best as we can even though these
things are heated for all of us
um to try to do what we did in the
discussion try to argue the point uh
even if we uh do not like many things I
want to talk about to speak what would
you respect I'm free in this country I
can speak with an assertive voice I
don't need people telling me how to
speak I've not been told that I cannot
speak in an assertive voice a discussion
doesn't exclude that but would you
respect I won't be told off this is a 21
five minute segment
no he was for two minutes that is a
runaway tactic he knows that he's got
nothing to say
thank you
they're talking about Prophet Muhammad
is homosexuality and attacking Islam I'm
telling you respond to my arguments
instead of trying to tell me off like a
little boy trust me I'm not a little boy
and every single man I'm a bigger man
yeah
so sorry sir we haven't we haven't
settled this yet so the issue is not
being told what to say or how to say it
right the issue is that there's a
uh there's a uh
there's a structural apartheid the way
you'll be dealt with right now
in the way I want to speak
I would like to be I would like to be
dealt with properly here let me put it
this way so just answer my questions I
don't want to be told how to speak
I'm speaking to you in a way you're just
you're being you're being harmonious and
you're trying to be the Schoolboy
teacher you're not here for that nope
no I actually that's why you spent three
minutes actually no question My Views
I'm not an atheist oh it doesn't matter
My Views are closer to yours
and I recognize
one of the discussions
if all of you agree that we can
sensitive Chad and I it gives us chance
to think all the things and then we'll
get back to our four panelists so do you
want to ask a question then I think as
the discussions leverage chat can say
that you know we are you going to come
in yes
I'm gonna bring in uh so I did promise
uh Aaron that you're gonna finish your
point okay yes so
I've been a lot I've spent a long time
preparing I read hamza's book and I
wanted to talk about some interesting
things so perhaps we could do that yes
please
so a number of your arguments and
Muhammad made this point about his
contingency argument there was this talk
about this problem with actual
Infinities which I found I think it's
fascinating is a really interesting and
a physical discussion to be had about
whether Infinities can be instant shaped
in reality
you are okay with mathematical
Infinities so you have no problems
talking about in a logical space that
mathematicians can talk about
mathematical Infinities so the
cardinalities of infinite sets or
potential infinite staff tend towards
Infinity like an asymptote you just
think that for some reason those can't
be instantiated in reality because that
is that a fair assessment of your of
your view that they can't be
instantiated in reality yeah yes to a
degree okay so I'm going to put forward
this argument for discussion so it's an
argument for atheism and I'm just
interested to get your both your input
on
would you respect I know this was a
distraction but I did ask a question and
there was a distraction so can you
answer my question before I answer yours
yeah why don't we get back to that after
he's given this yeah I have no problem
we can talk about rights and the
objective basis I have no problem
talking about them okay good you said
that you're a man of your word yeah 100
we'll talk we can talk about that we can
talk about moral realism and all of that
okay so let's just assume ex-hypophasy
that actual Infinities can't exist that
they can exist in a conceptual realm of
abstract logic and Mathematics
okay so here's the problem the problem
you might have heard before is that this
problem is how does it how does that
reconcile with God's Infinity now I know
the planet you've said that there's a
distinction between a qualitative
infinite and a quantitative yes right so
your normal response is when you're
challenged on the stuff God's Infinity
being instantiated in reality you say
know that this is a qualitative there's
no like accepted thing with God that's
infinite it's a way of talking about his
his acne his his all his all his good
practices
this is the problem that I want to post
and see how you guys deal with it
because I don't know I honestly I don't
think I've heard you respond to it so
the first premise is that God is
essentially omniscient so I take that to
be a fundamental future
so if God is omniscient then I take it
that his actual knowledge of all true
propositions
so premise three of arguments is then
that the cardinality of the set of
natural numbers
four is that there's a true proposition
about each member or element of the sets
of natural numbers
from that we can conclude that therefore
God has actual knowledge of Allah's true
propositions
having knowledge of an numerically
distinct proposition P entails having a
numerically distinct belief about
proposition P yes therefore God has
numerically distinct beliefs about true
proposition
a belief is an actually existing state
of an actual mind so beliefs are not
mathematical objects and they're not
abstraction they might be about abstract
objects they might be about abstraction
but beliefs themselves are states of the
mind even the Divine yes you're right so
therefore God has an actual aleph notes
which is the cardinality of the number
of beliefs in mind but if x hypothesis
actual infinities are impossible yeah by
the Assumption then we must conclude
that God is Not omniscient but if God is
Not omniscient then he's not essentially
omniscient and if it's a defining
feature of gods and Lucian studies
essentially on the scientific show then
he doesn't exist right so it seems to me
that the problem and maybe you will have
to retract on the idea of that actually
notice can't exist or you'll have a
different view about God's might Nathan
okay so that's that's not what you guys
think about this has been dealt with
extensively in the books of Kalam
actually because this actual question is
yes
I'm gonna answer you look so the the
distinction between quantitative and
qualitative has been made usually it's a
box standard answer that's given by
William Lynn Craig himself yes okay
actually it's connected to the Kalam
cosmological argument yes now the thing
is what is actually problematic about
the idea of an actual Infinity in the
real world so if you look for example I
have your Center's account and it's
interesting there's a lot of secondary
source materials and stuff like that and
other people's account as well Tamia
being one of them they don't have a
problem with the the instantiation of an
actual Infinity in the real world they
only have a problem with the actual
instantiation of the real world
considering certain conditions and I'll
tell you what they are okay yeah so
number one the condition is that these
things or have the uh they occupy a
space-time and number two is that they
coexist okay number three is that
they're Limited
again right they're limited data they
occupy space time and that they actually
exist right so for example many scholars
of um philosophy of religion Aristotle
believe this even Cena believed this
even timely believe this many people
believe it's not five Believers that
there was actually an infinite regrowth
of things they didn't see as an absurd
or they didn't believe it was they
connected it with the necessary being
the major differentiation that they put
in place was the following look at this
bottle for example this is limited would
you agree it's limited in this form in
certain properties yes
so so what they would say is that this
bottle which was contingent and limited
independent having an infinite amount of
these bottles at the same time okay that
is what would be impossible why would
that be impossible because number one
they're limited number two they're
contingent and number three that uh they
would have to coexist at the same time
so this with these conditions in mind
you see they would they would uh they
would discount the idea of an actual
Infinity it would say that in these
contexts wouldn't work with God now yes
he's not limited
so this is already a difference it's not
contingent so you see God is necessary
and necessary being by death must exist
but even the attributes of the necessary
being for example it must be misery
which means the idea of a quantitative
Infinity is not only not applicable to
him yes yes it's not applicable to him
number two it's something which is not
applicable to anything necessary
so so in other words yeah you see the
actual Infinities in the context of
limited things which coexist at the same
time as and which are dependent and
contingent that's where the gripe is
it's not where the idea of a a
um as you as you phrased it which is an
actual Infinity in the real world that's
why it's actually we do kind of believe
an actual infinite in real world only
with the necessary existence it's only
an actual Infinity we're all the same
condition as I just mentioned yeah no
okay sorry yeah no you want to go yeah
so if you're not mine so you said like
the belief God having a belief yeah
would mean that it's it's actualized in
the real world no no what I'm saying
yeah so what I'm saying is that you
believe that God is a mind right no no
we don't we don't God doesn't have
beliefs he doesn't have knowledge yeah
but he's got so many of us maybe I'm
confused yes it's God person so this
will be this is the only material person
so just just just to so we believe in
God's Transcendence right so you're
using things like mind and person is
something that doesn't really exist in
that traditionally yes
no no person a person yes sir uh person
with a mind yeah right that has yeah
subtle
um anthropomorphic connotation right
right so we wouldn't really fixate on
the term mind itself right okay that's
the first thing this way when I I want
to find out what do you mean by God's
beliefs and why are you saying that this
means that they are actualized I want to
yeah no I'm happy to so my general
understanding and maybe we are talking
across purpose yes because the idea that
I've always had of the the sort of being
that resonance for people that has that
is cashed out religiously is the idea
that people have a belief that God's
looking out for them he's essentially
he's a person and we are made in His
image and obviously God's not a fine
actress like as I take a few you guys
yeah he's Transcendent unlimited
unbounded so all of those sorts with the
words unlimited yeah you have to connect
it to an attribute of God although
because unintelligible okay if you say
Unlimited in Mercy Unlimited in power
Unlimited in knowledge superlative
knowing know about it yes so so so what
I'm saying is that I've always
understood that when people all pray to
God he can answer prayers yes God knows
God knows the amount of hairs that are
on hanza's head on your head yeah even
though iPhones
he knows what's going on with me and
Mark and these are distinct beliefs and
and normally when you think about a
Justified Justified True Believer just
go with JTB yeah
that any claim of knowledge implies
believe it's hard it's very hard to make
sense of what you mean by by God's
omniscience if we're not talking about
propositional love Yeah but my my
specific question is so I could not have
to address your point yeah because I
don't want to straw man no no no so when
you say God having a belief yeah and
then God having a belief means that
somehow actualized in the real world
what do you mean by oh okay and how to
demonstrate okay God has a belief and by
very by the very virtue he has a belief
it means it's actualization so when I
say God's belief is real I mean it's in
the same way that you think God is real
you have a problem with actual
Infinities you're saying that God's
attribute of knowledge must be actually
infinite because it's connected to
quantifiable things which have to have
to for example his own self America easy
for himself God's if he's boundless then
he must know himself right so in other
words he must have it's not quite what
I'm it's not quite nice I know but
you're saying that God's you have a
problem you're saying to me you have a
problem with actual Infinities right and
God's knowledge you're saying God's
knowledge is actually infinite so I'm
responding to you I don't have a problem
with actual Affinity I'm responding it's
my response yes I don't have a problem
even in the real world listen to what
I'm saying I can see it's logically not
always incoherent can you see I'm not
going okay yeah yeah because what you're
doing now is refuting William Lane
Craig's calendar I'm saying I accept I
accept what you're saying here it's a
strong point against the clapper's logic
argument I belong to it but what I'm
saying is this is the response this is
what I'm saying please yeah you might
want to write this down
which is this I'm saying I have a
problem with actual Infinities in the
certain context number one that the the
objects of of in question in actual
Infinities number one are contingent
number two are limited number three
exist all at the same time that's the
thing that every scholar of the of the
medieval story is explained to me so I'm
trying to understand yes sorry let me
explain yeah okay so sorry
imagine God created a then create B then
create C and those Infinity that was it
the thing is you that's a view in this
line
is
many people believe this Aristotle
believe this do you see what I'm saying
it's a view in the philosophy of
religion I'm not saying logically is
fully problematic yeah I'm saying the
following saying if you get all of the
if you get all those Infinities at the
same time all those things a b c add
infinity and put them all at the same
time
the existence of those contingent
Limited
existence is together that's where the
confliction lies why because therein
lies the absurdities of the part being
more than the whole that the inexorable
becomes the exhausted all those things I
mentioned the presentation that's where
it would be a problem where the spatial
temporal time Dimension is one I.E they
all coexist yes all those things exist
at the same time number one and number
two that they're Limited in contingent
do you understand what I'm saying no I
think I understand what you're saying I
would like to finish my pregnancy
because because uh so it's a little bit
of a strong man to consider the
qualitative versus the uh uh
what did you say I said in my book I
forgot I call it the qualitative
qualitative and quantitative in the book
is actually goes a little bit further
and it echoes what hijab is saying is
it's more about the differentiating
undifferentiated instrument this is the
point so it's based on a temporal
spatial discrete things finite discrete
things so there is a fundamental
difference so we accept the actual
infinite
we can't accept it but we don't accept
it from the point of view that you can
have an actual infinite that is based on
differentiated things which is based on
the contingency their limited nature
so God's knowledge no scholar on Earth
will say God's knowledge is is is is a
differentiated uh
Eternal a limited attribute from the
point of view that it's temporal spatial
and it has uh these limitations and
that's why I wanted to really find out
what you have I believe I think and how
that actually denies uh what we're
saying I can't see that the argument
that you propose actually actually is a
defeating so before you could you um
I'll let you finish your points
quickly bring in Dr Chad Harris and then
we can continue this
um with audience questions perhaps on
this point or other boys
I'm just saying what is the ontological
epistemological grounding that this is a
morality on a projective level
so so the view that iot is maybe a
slightly different tomorrow although
Mark didn't mention it yeah which is
that I think that a good way to ground
an objective ethics is to look at the
nature of satra so when an entity
suffers one of the things that they
learn about the suffering the actual
nature of it is that it has an
axiological valence so in other words we
learn about the axiological Dust value
of suffering through knowledge fire
acquaintances to our direct acquaintance
with the state of suffering and I think
that that's now we can cash that out in
slightly different ways I mean some some
meta-ethicists will cash that out
getting a reductive account so some
people will say they're much like in the
philosophy of mine we want to reduce
qualitative properties to neural States
certain mental emphasis think that it's
appropriate to reduce suffering to
certain the Badness of suffering the
normative property to sufferings and I
think that that's quite plausible
another way of looking at it is to say
that it's non-reductive so in other
words that the normative property
supervenes in a necessary way on the on
the non on the non-normative property of
saffron another way is to look at it is
a functionalist account now all of those
various accounts they're very
interesting in meta ethics but that's
more an in-house debate amongst
meta-emphasis but once you've grant that
suffering is intrinsically bad it may be
instrumentally good in some cases but
once you grant that it's intrinsically
that that generates a moral reason yeah
okay
so once we have a moral reason that's
amenable to rational
um to rational understanding yes we can
start to think about rights because once
we recognize that there's an axiological
dissonance or a negative axiological
valence to suffering we can see that
that NC has an interest a moral interest
in not something and that has a rational
skill to have a right and what is a
right a right is a claim that an entity
has to protect its vital interests and
one of the vital interests that it has
is the interest in not suffering why
because suffering is intrinsically so
that's so that's something this is the
this is
listen David Hume style this is all
fallacies naturally fallacy because what
you're saying is suffering you feel is
bad therefore is bad from an or is
perspective dude don't do perspective
detailological Spectrum oral perspective
the point is I don't even want you to
premise that suffering is bad in the
first place some suffering is good we
all go to the gym and suffer them
I don't even grind the premise we suffer
all the time as I mentioned before I
gave you a live example the people that
were the good people in South Africa
that went against the apartheid for so
many years decades I'm sure you're one
of them your rights activist yourself
were suffering against the hegemonic
power until they achieved their
achievement so I don't even Grant ideas
the point is you saying that suffering
you feel bad therefore is bad is a
naturalistic fallacy David Hume who is
an atheist himself said you shouldn't be
doing this that's not grounding
objective morality so that's the
question again how can you grant
groundbreaking yeah so one response to
that is you've conflated the intrinsic
versus the non-intrinsic nature of sex
so in the axiological theory there's two
distinctions important category
distinctions that are happening there
one is about the intrinsic nature of the
intrinsic value of something the other
one is the non-intrinsic what you're
referring to is a non-intrinsic value of
suffering so suffering is quite
suffering or mental steps the state of
being in pain is itself bad in and of
itself it may be extrinsically good in
the sense that it helps you to overcome
certain things like for example I can
see Hamza likes to train as well as you
are we like to train a gym right so that
so so the instrumental value of
suffering we can grant them right it's a
non-intronsense
just one more thing yeah I think what
you've done is conflicted the
psychologically ethical like for example
what you're saying is that we don't like
pain I agree with you we don't like pain
human beings don't like pain is bad for
the most part I understand that but what
we're talking about here is a kind of
psychological bat not an ethical
teleological matter how do you get from
the psychological to ethical how are you
making that jump there's another
question I think would help this because
I would like to ask you yeah because I
think you've slightly skipped something
very important when we say objective
yeah or when you say objective what do
you mean I mean because if you ground so
if you ground more values in a
naturalistic paradigm yeah or you're
growing more values in what you would
say intrinsic suffering for example
how does that make you objective because
my understanding objective is that
irrespective of the whole world right if
they were to say that for example
apartheid is right and we still know it
is wrong yes because more values are out
there so to speak so they require an
ontological grounding you have to answer
two key ontological questions okay
number one what is what is the source of
this moral value and what makes it mind
independent what you've done actually
you've just gone around in circles
but wait one more so you really
understand what I'm trying to say
because this is philosophy right yeah
yeah no we're doing you said naturalism
explains everything yeah yeah so under
what naturalistic account if naturalism
is defined as metaphysical naturally
defined as yes number one there is no
Divine there is no non-physical and
everything can be reduced to or
explained by physical performance
phenomena in some way
you want you doing you're enchanting
physical phenomena with some kind of
divine attributes on on non-physical uh
features so for my from that point of
view you'd have to also Define what
physical uh properties are or what
physical problems
all these other people there's a change
and you can have a discussion and you
will answer them you cannot negate all
these other people I'm sorry that I'm
overriding my chair I'm being out
reported by doing that but I'm asking
I'm asking you to have some respect for
others and then we can speak about
religion and totality so can you let the
chair do what he needs to do and we he
will come back to and let you speak but
people here need to ask questions too
because
foreign
[Music]
Ty as possible which means I don't have
any Undeclared negative attentions and I
think you know I believe in sometimes
over Collective Consciousness and energy
permeates the room and from the
beginning prior to this conversation we
had academics saying we need academics
on the panel because an academic
University because we have to
academically they're not it's not your
words but it came across we have to
academically babysit the panel and that
and I I'm being honest that was what
those were the words we're here because
academically needs some academic
professionals to give you an academic
input Lord respect you have master's
degrees you have PhD PhD when almost
finishing we have he has more degrees
than a thermometer so the point is
foreign
I'm totally wrong but I got the kind of
feeling
that there is almost a sense of you know
metal type of babysitting going on yeah
and yes there was emotions but I think
we're gentleman he knows look he's a man
let me tell you 100 he knew what he was
going to say was going to trigger
something yeah so guaranteed we live in
a hegemonic liberal circumcise that's
imposing on the Muslim Community and
it's not a neutral space ideological but
we need to wrap up I'm trying to say
that has to be clear because that's how
it has come across from the beginning
before we've entered this room and we
had we're having a really good
philosophical discussion and with due
respect uh the part the what's your name
the the the the chair has already
assessed that we're going to give more
time to discussion than to q a it was
already agreed with all due respect
you're subordinate in this in this
conversation and you should allow him to
do his job he interrupted which was fine
but you didn't know why he interrupted
let him interrupt properly if you want
to take it to the audience that's fair
enough but with what you expect let's
not have any Undeclared negative
intentions that we're all neutral and
equal on this panel and platform there
is no I'm academic I'm up here I need
babysitting all this and the other we're
gentlemen we have our own personalities
and let's have a conversation I just
find it was rude I was interrupted when
we're having a really good philosophical
exclusive that's what I'm saying okay
we're going to continue with this
discussion at Dr Harrison
um
Dr mati are going to be brought in and I
appreciate Dr mati um uh trying to
bring us in bring you in and then the
the audience but please go ahead so it's
a narrow argumentative point I'm not
going to take sides either way in this
but I felt you know even started off by
presenting an argument that ostensibly
is an argument about evil
and then Muhammad came in and said you
know you denied evil
um objectively a substrate okay and you
said actually there's just good and
there's a lack of good so is the good is
the good something that admits of degree
so you can have greater or lesser good
yes suddenly argument still goes through
because all that's needed for the audio
to go through is for you to have less
good
respect so the notion of evil yeah
[Music]
my point was in response to that was
that evil doesn't have an ontological
status you cannot put it it's not
substrating you cannot put under a
microscope I'm not making a point about
the relational type of evil you can say
that evil exists I'm seeing as an
atheist how can you substantiate my
question was how can you substantiate
the existence of something on atheism
objectively which doesn't happen but
that's irrelevant to his argument I
think it's very relevant no it's not
on the basis all he needs for his
argument to work is if good can admit of
degrees if you can have a greater or
less amount of good then the arguments
are sound argument and now I feel like
three on one another problem three or
two you need to do this I'm sure you do
which is the fact that we talked about
Divine wisdom anyway which is that we
Divine wisdom is not mentioned
types of uh evil
it's not mentioned
I'm not asking about it it's not
mentioned even in his argument because
Divine wisdom wisdom and Arabic language
means what are shaking mechanism
basically it's appropriate what are you
laughing at this is also relevant to the
audience
you aren't you aren't answering my
question
you're laughing why are you laughing for
because you are deflecting no I'm not
deflecting
my question is this when you when you
talk about God you're talking about all
of the attributes that Muslims speak
about when we talk about God including
but not limited to the wisdom of God now
I'm saying that the existence of evil
doesn't negate the
e of God because wisdom is appropriacy
it could be appropriate unless you want
to say it's a fundamentally
inappropriate for them to be a world in
which evil exists and that's appropriate
because as the handles also will say you
know only the pixel and God knows the
picture you have the totality of
knowledge you don't know everything that
exists in other words and also from a
logical perspective just to address your
point let's assume that that so what
Muhammad hijab means about good having
levels is in a kind of a modern Expo
into the real world sure does have
levels in the real world but
ontologically say good is non-existent
good it says existing and absolute let's
assume that and we have wisdom that
existence absolutely what we're saying
is that evil itself is actually a
manifestation of absolute unchanging
good and absolute unchanging wisdom yeah
in a real world sense so even from that
perspective there are theological
accounts where you can say yeah the
goodness and wisdom of God actually
ground evil in a real world sense but
evil doesn't have its ontological status
is actually good and based on wisdom
that actually under undermines the
logical argument in my view mind if I
respond to that because there was no
love
so
yeah no talking and takes Divine wisdom
into account
okay so the idea is that prior to godson
it's just the argument into simplistic
terms
the idea is that the feast is committed
to three distinct propositions about God
the first is God's unsurpassable
greatness that includes his omniscience
which is includes his wisdom his
omnipotence and his app Supreme
axiological dad right so it's
omniscience in Islam is different from
his wisdom okay so no sense so let's so
let's say that that also includes his
wisdom
let's let's say they say that part of
his superlative
the idea is that prior to the existence
of any natural world so the created
order God is independent you this is
part of this is your point that you want
to emphasize which I was independent to
be created also there's a difference
between the Creator and the Creator yes
so prior to any creation you have this
all that is existing is a superlative
being
and the core argument that schillenberg
puts forward is that the fiesta is also
committed to what he calls prior purity
of God so in other words there's no
Goods in Eve there are no Goods in mind
that have any relationship to evil
whatsoever so there's no God is in some
sense axiologically unblemished okay so
he's pure okay and the point that he's
trying to get across in this new logical
argument from Evil yes is trying to say
well how do you bridge the gap
if you start off with the being that is
superbly great can't be great yeah sure
sure and is axiologically pure yes in
all goodness there's no evil in God
there's nothing anything that
presupposes evil so you may even think
that there's nothing like courage in God
prior to existence okay okay but let's
not be dismissal I'm trying to give the
argument here so the idea is that from
that state any omniscient and wise being
would judge that all the pure Goods in
him are better than any sorts of Fine
Art Goods and the idea of the argument
the thrust of the argument is that God
would model the world you know after the
goods that are in here in other words he
would make a world that is more God luck
yeah yeah right okay so basically the
Islamic tradition yeah there's there's
differences
so gentlemen I'll let you finish that uh
we've been given uh now seven and a half
minutes to
wrap things up I'll let you finish your
point let me finish the point there's a
different sort of thought so there's
Divine cups just like in Christianity
like Augustine and Thomas Aquinas and so
on they had the school field this is
called The Odyssey and in that they had
the idea of privation okay I also
believe in that there's Divine Commander
which is that something is good because
God said it that's that's uh also
represented in the example there's two
ways to answer this question let's go
with the privation too for the sake of
the login because all the one-way solve
this issue I'm saying the following I'm
saying that look if God is all good it's
like for example do you see this light
over there you see like yeah yeah okay
so what is goodness is the reflection of
the life evil is the removal of the
light right okay you understand so good
is when God chooses to manifest his
attribute of goodness that is the
privation theory of good you understand
what I'm trying to say so it doesn't
require him to have an evil in him to
remove the goodness or remove
manifestation but do you understand the
sound yeah no I get it I get I get I get
the point but yeah but then there's the
point that um gave to you which is
exactly that you can run the same
argument I don't need to talk about
um when we can run shellenberg's
argument without talking about evil we
can talk about there exists a world with
a distinct absence of good okay
so that's that's in other words in other
words in other words you see the point
so the point is the world Falls
substantially
yeah here's the thing yeah okay in the
first half answers
and then we can take questions because I
do get the feeling he spoke about three
minutes
give me one side there is a there is a
there is a phrase by mem
one of the Great Schools of Islam he
says that laser fill in can
[Applause]
there's nothing in the creation better
than what is
this is kind of connecting what you're
talking about okay so there's a long
discussion among Islam Scholars about
what this means
because it's connected so you're coming
with good interrogations I'm not I'm not
actually dismissing what you're saying
what he's saying is something that
Islamic scholar spoke about for a
thousand years no problem you're you're
coming with good interrogations
now the response to that like if I wrote
a book on that very phrase
can you tell me what the answer that he
gave us is it possible
we have to yeah so so I I believe that
there is a problem with the body
there is an assumption that there is a
distinction between ontological good and
a real world evil
is that correct
uh it's not quite what the audience is
getting no I'm talking about the
Assumption of the argument so what
you're saying is there is a good God has
Goods right it's perfect being good he's
Omni benevolent right and there is an
evil what are you making an ontological
distinction between evil existing and
God's goodness all right if what we
would say is in actual fact even itself
does not have an ontological existence
it is a manifestation of the perfect
goodness and the perfect wisdom so one
that's the theistic position of Islam so
the whole logic is actually a strong man
of Islamic theism it would only work if
you conflate omniscience with God's
wisdom which there is a subtle
difference and only there is a an
assumption in the logic that there is an
ontological difference between uh good
and evil and evil itself has some kind
of grounding or ontology we will say
that's not the Islamic theistic Discord
the Islamic discourse is excuse God is
good with me excuse me
sorry I was supposed to have five
minutes is not going to be sorry and you
can call me rude it's fine I live with
them what what I'm saying this is
I'm going to start with a gentleman
outside
it strikes me are we opened up in a god
truth morality there are men getting
cold outside it's very cold workers
working for us people I didn't know that
yeah no I'm telling you that okay thank
you so let me see we speak about God
reality where do they effectively that
man told me we need to be out by one
minute so I'm not even going to finish
okay we
people needed to ask questions but
because you have four men what truly
interested owning themselves
with their truth with their correctness
you could have been more humbling
no because you've been speaking one
another so what I'm asking you know
[Applause]